[Music]
it is a baby bump seen around the world
look how sweet this is a black and white
photo of prince harry and meghan markle
released on instagram look how they're
looking at each other that looks like
love to me
along with the news that the couple is
expecting their second baby this photo
was taken remotely on an ipad by a
photographer and a friend
a spokesperson for the duke and duchess
of sussex confirmed the baby news
charlie daggett is outside buckingham
palace charlie what's the reaction from
the royal family
good morning outside buckingham palace
with some happy news to share now a
statement from the palace said
her majesty the duke of edinburgh the
prince of wales that's prince charles
and the entire royal family are
delighted and wish them well
as you said a valentine's day
announcement and team sussex says it's a
happy coincidence that came on the very
same day
37 years ago princess diana announced
her pregnancy with prince harry
now the news comes after the duchess
suffered a miscarriage last summer
judging from that baby bump she was
almost certainly pregnant when she
shared her
deeply personal story in the new york
times last november
so 8th in line to the throne behind big
brother archie
and prince harry who said in a 2019
interview he would only have two
children
for the sake of the planet now let's
assume the baby will be born in the
united states it's a question of when
the queen
will meet her great-grandchild she
hasn't seen archie
since the couple left the uk around 18
months ago
gail charlie i love happy coincidences i
thought it was so interesting to hear
that that was the same day that diana
released it on valentine's day
the news that harry was coming it's
great news so listen
megan is expected to give birth here in
this country will that mean that the
baby will be an american citizen
uh yes but not necessarily because the
baby will be born in the united states
if
the child is born to a british father
and an american mother it's the same
situation for me and my children
american father and a british mother
they have dual national um there are
dual nationals
for as long as they want to for the rest
of their lives unless they choose
otherwise one interesting thing to note
is that the child is
born in the united states he or she may
grow up
to one day be the president
wouldn't that be it is it the talk of
the uk charlie i'm curious
you know it's huge news gail you know
they've had a difficult time here with
the media
uh recently as you're well aware but on
every front page it's just been accepted
with this great
sense of celebration um so yes it's
it's a huge deal here everybody's
celebrating that announcement that
they're delighted the palace would say
that anyway
but people that we've spoken to have got
contacts in the palisade
they are actually delighted i mean you
know what isn't great news
about a baby on the way i know i'd like
to think people are cheering them on
always thank you charlie dagetta
reporting from london